curieuse lit on dans encore fumé du
cannabis c'est interdit sauf si on est
malade
le cannabis perturberait un neurone
habituellement chargé de transmettre
l'information sur la satiété
c'est-à-dire l'information selon
laquelle le corps a eu sa dose et que
c'est plus la peine de manger à la place
le neurone perturbé se mettra à
transmettre le signal de la fin c'est à
dire le message exactement inverse
faites le mauvais message ça peut être
très positif c'est même l'une des
indications de ce qu'on appelle le
cannabis thérapeutique où le cannabis
médical
on peut l'utiliser pour stimuler
l'appétit des patients qui n'en n'ont
plus à cause de leur maladie et
notamment à cause du sida
le cannabis peut aussi servir à calmer
les nausées en cas de chimiothérapie il
est aussi utilisé pour atténuer
certaines douleurs et des spasmes
musculaires notamment dans les scléroses
en plaques
il a aussi des vertus relaxantes
susceptibles de soigner des troubles du
sommeil il est aussi employé dans le
traitement d'une maladie des yeux qu'on
appelle le glaucome attention usage du
cannabis médical dans les pays où il est
autorisé c'est très réglementé
il faut avoir une ordonnance et ça
consiste rarement à fumer c'est petit
joint aux klm
sauf si c'est dépénaliser les
laboratoires ont créé des médicaments à
base de thé acheter sous différentes
formes comme le sativex qui un spray
buccal prescrit dans le cadre de la
sclérose en plaques marinol des gélules
d'un thc de synthèse le trou nabinaud
halle qui stimule l'appétit est calme
les nausées et toujours contre les
nausées le sésame est des capsules à
base de nabi l'hôpital
le cannabis et ses dérivés pourraient
aussi avoir d'autres vertus qu'on pas
été strictement démontré contre les
cancers l'asthme l'épilepsie et même
certaines maladies psychiatriques
mais en france les médicaments à base de
cannabis sont autorisés depuis 2013
seulement et s'est pas encore
complètement rentré dans les bons mais
si c'est tellement bon pour la santé
qu'on en donne même malade
pourquoi ces interdits pour les autres
alors d'abord parce que si on a créé des
médicaments c'est pour pouvoir contrôler
la quantité thc qui contiennent qui est
très variable et qu'on maîtrise pas du
tout dans l'herbe ou dans la résine
ensuite parce que fumer ça irrite les
voies respiratoires
les études sont encore insuffisantes
pour affirmer à coup sûr que c'est
cancérogènes mais ce qu'on sait c'est
que la fumée de cannabis ça contient des
substances nocives
même si c'est de l'art me tueur alors
celle du site coupe ehf notre tracteur a
mélangé à du tabac
alors faut aussi savoir que le cannabis
ça rend pas forcément cool détendu et
plein d'amour
d'ailleurs le mot assassin ça vient des
haschischins qui étaient des tueurs à
qui on donnait du hachish avant d
envoyer au combat
alors ok à l'époque les produits étaient
beaucoup plus puissants que ce qui
circule aujourd'hui
mais quand même il faut savoir que le
thc à petite dose ça détend mais à haute
dose ça peut provoquer des accès
d'anxiété voir des attaques de panique
pour ceux qui ont une prédisposition il
ya aussi ceux des compensées des
troubles psychiatriques
attention ça veut pas dire que ça rend
fou mais ça peut déclencher le passage
vers la maladie chez quelqu'un qui a un
terrain pour ça mais en réalité ce qui
est peut-être l'effet le plus
indésirables du cannabis et celui là sur
la mémoire et sur la motivation le tht
perturbe la mémoire à court terme et la
concentration ce qui diminue la capacité
d'apprendre et c'est dommage parce que
les adolescents sont des gros
consommateurs de cannabis et à cette
époque de notre vie on apprend quand
même un paquet de trucs en plus les
effets pourraient ne pas s'arrêter à la
période de consommation une étude
néo-zélandaise a démontré que les
personnes qui avaient fumé surtout s'il
avait commencé jeune aient encore plus
ils la mettaient beaucoup et pendant
longtemps il avait une moins bonne
mémoire que les autres même s'ils
avaient arrêtés et selon une autre étude
brésilienne celle là si on a commencé à
fumer avant 15 ans on risque d'avoir des
facultés intellectuelles inférieur aux
autres
ça s'explique par le fait que dans ces
cas là le tht perturberait un cerveau en
pleine maturation qui du coup ne se
développerait pas correctement et là
encore les troupes pourrait se prolonger
à l'âge adulte les effets sur la
motivation sont aussi très complexe mais
une partie de l'explication vient de
l'action du thc sur la dopamine et
d'endocannabinoïdes ont aussi un rôle
dans la libération de la dopamine qui
joue elle un rôle clé dans le plaisir à
nos palin c'est donc la substance du
plaisir mais elle gère aussi le système
de récompense de notre corps c'est à
dire qu'elle procure une sensation
bien-être quand on a effectué des tâches
nécessaires à notre survie comme manger
par exemple ou avoir des activités qui
ont pour but d'assurer la pérennité de
l'espèce
quand quelqu'un fume du cannabis il
s'offre une bonne dose de dopamine qui
fait plaisir mais s'il le fait
régulièrement et à fortes doses il
risque de dérégler son système de
récompense comment va en augmentant le
seuil de dopamine à partir de laquelle
il ressent bien être au point qu'au bout
d'un moment il n'y a plus que le tht qui
peut vraiment lui offrir ce qui explique
le désintérêt plus ou moins marqué pour
tout le reste
voilà ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que
tout le monde réagit pas de la même
façon au thc donc au cannabis mais que
les effets les plus négatifs c'est ce
qu'on observe chez ceux qui en
consomment tôt dans leur vie
l'idée c'est de considérer ça comme une
substance chimique dont on fait des
médicaments et de ne pas oublier que
pour l'instant en france en consomme et
fait encore un délice
dtc c'est fini pour aujourd'hui donc on
passe aux travaux pratiques parce que
6,6 en veux tu saches rouler avant ce
soir c'est la consigne en attendant
trouver des moyens d'offrir des chocs de
dopamine sans risque et surtout portez
vous bien